yeah yeah third video was running this
is about the Queens gambit declined um
exchange variation actually because I
really recommend to to take on on d5
here 85 Bishop g5 so why why the
exchange variation actually I think it's
a very good idea to play this here
because of two reasons first it's maybe
just the best line from an objective
point of view it's it's it's just
promises more advantage then than
anything else here in the Queens gambit
and then also it's the less some
interestingly enough it it involves the
less that's amount of theory to study in
comparison to two other lines for
instance if you don't take on d5 and
play another three it's possible no no
doubt about it but no black has a huge
choice he can play takes on on c4 he
can't play Bishop before he can just
play classical there should be seven and
then you need to try to get something
against the likes of the Lasker
variation or terekhova and so on it's
it's a huge huge amount of theory and
it's it's really a better option to just
play in the exchange of variation here
it's it's easier to play and it's just
promises white more I think and let's
have a quick quick look mmm the first
thing that needs to be explained why why
does white exchange on d5 doesn't it
help black to to get its bishop out
immediately yes it does the bishop
doesn't have the problem anymore from
the the pawn on e6 blocking but what has
got some other advantages in comparison
his has got an extra pawn in the sand
see point has been exchanged for deform
for a pawn and it's actually pretty
tricky to to get this Bishop on CA to
develop somehow I would almost say it's
not possible to do it in an active way
let's have a quick look here on blacks
main move here as c6 we can also play
Bishop e7 or 9b d7 it doesn't make much
of a difference usually and I don't know
80 to 90 percent of the games you get
the same position over and over again
now III Bishop d7 let's play this is
played mostly here just a quick remark
about Bishop f5 which is looking very
logical because it develops the bishop
and it anticipates why playing we should
be three that black would serve just
exchange but White has an annoying move
here [ __ ] knight Knight and queen to f3
and this is really annoying for black
this is still playable line but usually
you get to something like this the
bishop is detect that needs to retreat
and this is really an endgame which what
can can play for a win for like 50 years
60 100 moves and black just has a very
thankless task of defending this
position it's it's playable but it's all
has been played by some grandmasters
actually but it's it's it's not not a
real joy to play this as black you you
should take this happily and as as white
there should be seven now Bishop d3 not
be g7 and now one point of this whole
move order on white plays Knight to e2
and not to f3 which
is perfectly fine but here you see one
advantage of not committing the knight
to f3 early because white has got the
option to actually use this gray to
black now castles Quincy to rupee eight
just normal and now well my
recommendation would be to play short
Castle here but it's also interesting
maybe you can just mix move orders to go
for long castle this is very aggressive
of course white is idea to play on h3g
for magic dream and just go for a huge
King side attack which is dangerous
really it's very sharp line you can you
can go for this but the the main line
here is just the short cast that this is
a line that scores really heavily for
white I don't know it's certainly above
60%
I guess close to 70% it's very difficult
to play for black usually black plays
Knight of 8 to get the bishop out
somewhere and then f3 and White's idea
here is to expand in the center with E
for after some preparation it's usually
not possible to play it the next move
but you often times need to put rook on
g1 first so you want our King h1 to get
the King out of the diagonal here but
then go for a form and try to really
build up a huge Center it's often leads
to great attacking positions for white
after you for captures on e4 every form
it's very it's a very nice position
um this is a line that many black
players like to avoid and this is also
the point
of a very interesting move order which
is which should be 7 lots of black
players here especially if they have put
in some study on play Bishop e7 first
and not Bishop g5 and the idea is that
if white wants to go for the exchange
variation with em what I recommend to do
this nevertheless but here cause white
and cannot play Bishop g5 it's just
hanging and okay what what move from
surely play and Bishop f4 of course but
this is just a different line so with
Bishop e7 in terms of facing the
exchange variation black has just
avoided the specific line I just showed
with the long line with f3 at the end
this position Bishop e7 is really played
only to avoid this line and because
black doesn't mind if Y plays for
instance Knight f3 Knight f6 this is no
huge concern it just leads to two other
lines but black just plays this move
because he's some more willing to play
this position than the other position
with f3 at the end ok I also recommend
to to exchange him it it has still got
some good possibilities to play for an
advantage it's not as powerful as the
other kind of exchange line but it just
makes sense to combine this to two lines
a black mostly plays c6 here then III
and Bishop f5 this is played mostly
there's some other ideas but this is
played mostly and it's just the line you
have to look at them if you prepare this
for white
because it's the eternal question can
black develop this bishop really are is
there some issue with this there are
actually a smaller than one issue one
interesting idea which is very
aggressive and fits well with the other
lines is Veggie for him and I would move
off we can't vote Vinick Bishop e6 some
main move Bishop g6 also possible but
it's answered by by the same move now
black can buy white can actually even
play h4 which is very aggressive takes
lots of space on the on the Kings side
and what is really dangerous here from
black would actually capture on edge for
this is hanging Queen b3 then it's a
very annoying move because b7 is
attacked and black also needs to protect
the bishop on h4 so it just has to move
b6 and then white really makes huge
progress not a3 with the tempo there
should be 795 and now one possible line
Knight f6 g5 knight retreats and then
even g6 and white it's got a huge attack
it's just just looks awful for black to
to defend this position this is just one
one example of course black can defend
by Telesis a bit a bit cooperative to to
take on h4 other lines that are
interesting here are actually my g2 and
then not g3 for instance let's say 9 of
693 and then H for H 6 H 5 visual edge
10 we should be 3 the ideas to now
exchange this because black or has
committed to h6 and then if this bishop
psyche change what will get an add on f5
and this is really annoying so white has
some idea to play for an edge
just a different kind of exchange
variation and compare to to the other
one but it's it's very nice you've
gotten very clean and solid structure
and the stable structure in the center
always gives some possibilities to play
on the flank like g4 and so on it's it's
interesting and white still has got some
possibilities to various just it's not
one specific move mode and if this
doesn't work it's it's a problem for
instance in the recent Russian
Championships more rows of which
actually played 83 I think and I'm not
100% sure something like this happened
okay
and I'm not sure it's possible a lot of
interesting active possibilities other
moves you have to look at briefly here
on move - I didn't tell anything yet
about the chicken and the Albin's well
as the Albans there's actually a very
simple line with a three and it's very
doubtful that black can egg equalize
this I think this is just better for
white plain and simple um black can of
course sacrifice the pawn with f6 and
something but this is of course playable
in in blitz or bully chess or something
but in a in a real tournament game while
it's just a pawn up one point of a3 is
just to prevent Bishop deform and very
often black responds with a five and
then white can can simply play is a 3e
so III and then he doesn't have to check
anymore so he's reduced to Bishop chief
c5 e D Bishop takes
um I actually forgot the line its Knight
takes Queen takes
I'm not sure I didn't look this up
beforehand the main point is white of
course loses the Pawnee five back but he
just got the bishop and an open position
and this is not very attractive for
black it's gonna be maybe some kind of
slight disadvantage at best
yeah well the chicken white has got many
options I think you should choose off or
between two lines 93 which might need to
line like this with the e4 to follow or
the other line which is possible as CD
525 III be 5 night ops 93 Bishop to b4
Bishop d2 takes and now context which is
also very aggressive and with ideas of
later playing f3 and f4 which is similar
to two other lines of the repertoire
well um yeah time is it's closing here
um please also check out the next video
as I will do some book recommendation
about the lines I just showed